[Music]
leave it to rihanna and asap rocky to
throw the most epic baby shower ever i
know thank you so much the couple
celebrated their bundle of joy on friday
and according to hip hollywood it was a
rave themed baby shower in la yep you
heard me a rave themed baby shower and
knowing re it was big colorful and
bright
now a source tells e.t that while the
two considered canceling the celebration
amid rocky's recent arrest and reports
of infidelity they decided to go ahead
with it flying out some family and
friends from barbados for what we're
told was a very intimate event what are
you looking forward to as you move into
a new chapter of your life
i'm just excited for what i don't know
yet you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited the source adds
that doing a co-ed shower was always the
plan rihanna didn't want to shower for
just the ladies they're in this together
it was always going to be a joint
celebration
as for that rave theme according to et
source it's no surprise they went for
something a little edgier than your
basic brunch
[Music]
according to reports guests weren't
allowed to record video or snap photos
and riri and rocky's crew came dressed
in their brightest neon ensembles which
according to et source is super on brand
quote rihanna has a great sense of humor
and loves to have fun what are you
enjoying most about this journey uh
donuts so far
but besides the obvious you know
i'm looking forward to it you know this
is it's all an exciting journey so far
i'm just taking it as it comes every
week it's something new
and i'm just taking it i'm enjoying it
and speaking of sense of humor fashion
retailer boohoo man who rocky's worked
with in the past
shared these shirts on twitter party
favors from the 33 year old rapper and
the 34 year old singer reading quote i
went to re and rocky's rave shower and
all i got was this amazing shirt it was
fun of course the shower comes amid a
series of controversies surrounding the
couple since they announced ree's
pregnancy in january the journey has
been incredible it's
a lot of hard work most recently on
april 20th rocky was arrested for
assault with a deadly weapon in
connection with a november 2021 shooting
he was released on 550 000
bail and prior to his arrest rumors
spread online that the grammy winner had
cheated on his pregnant girlfriend but
despite the drama a source told et last
week that there's no question that
rihanna will continue standing by his
side quote rihanna hasn't wavered she
loves him he's family
[Music]